la semaine dernière gérard pas bio dans
sa grande fresque intitulée au pignon
sur rue avait abordé le thème de
l'accord musical et de ses difficultés
se laver cela vous avez passionné vous
nous aviez téléphoner savons donc
chercher le coupable est aujourd'hui
gérard a voulu sonder la france au sujet
d'un certain ludwig b de son ami jean
sébastien de leur célèbre compères folk
en l'amadeus la mer de debussy ça vous
dit quelque chose
huit accords mais elles l'ont lui qui
était à mon avis cette fête est un
peintre non je pense et la mer de
debussy
non non je connais vraiment pas toute la
famille un parent lui qu'on entend
parler comme ça mais autrement le fait
qu'il ait fait des fugues jean sébastien
bach pas d'accord qu'ils fassent ce qui
voudra apparaître malhonnête
malheur à ça c'est sa musique qui
m'intéresse bien écouter on peut dire
c'est une malhonnêteté d'avoir fait des
fugues nord mais jean-sébastien bach
ouais c'est un personne n'est à l'abri
de faire des bêtises
la walkyrie ça vous dit quelque chose
qu'il est dans la boîte avec plusieurs
types massoud en dise et puis c'est très
bon comment imaginez-vous le boléro de
ravel madame j'imagine qu'on peut le
faire de plusieurs formes
on peut faire un arrondi
si avec tourné avec un petit noeud ou
alors tout simplement avec des boutons
ce moment là on le fait un point tombe
avec boîte
avez vous entendu parler d'othello
monsieur
l'écrivain non un peintre othello bas je
pense que c'est quand même assez assez
gênant c'est bien pratique d'avoir le
courante à domicile si je vous dis de
cosi fan tutte
qu'est ce que ça vous dit j'y connais
rien du tout alors que si je sais c'est
à dire eh bien c'est ali d'angle avec un
9 2 voies est-ce que la périchole vous
voyez ce que c'est monsieur des
percolateurs cancer et qui marchait
l'écrêtement c'est un petit percolateur
électriques pour faire du café près
c'est quoi avez vous entendu parler du
mariage de figaro madame
un regroupement social de entre le
figaro télé 7 jours l'europe
marie-claire jours et vous parlez de la
truite de schubert
elle ne connaît pas expliqué moi ce que
c'est expliquez moi ce que c'est de ce
que vous connaissez dans ce domaine ou
alors rien du tout dans le poisson je
vous dis j'ai écrit pêcheurs que sont
les études de chopin votre avis gageons
croit le bateau là je crois le
baccalauréat il ya cette époque était
quelque chose de formidable
vous comprenez qu'on parle des polonaise
de chopin non je suis pas d'accord là
dessus la vie privée des gens
personnel et c'est pas parce qu'il a il
a fait il a écrit ainsi de suite qu'on
doit s'occuper de la vie privée des gens
les trompettes d'aïda ça vous dit
quelque chose
non monsieur bambino d'accord pour moi
babbino cette chanson que je connais de
dalida
tu peux vraiment certains petits
morceaux que je veux bien combiné au
bambino
je sais bien que tu l'as d'or bambino et
gratte gratte sur ta mandoline et mon
petit bambino ta musique est plus joli
que sous le ciel de l'italie mais c'est
pas les trompettes d'aïda annoncé
bambino messieurs 2 de dalida
vous savez c'est promis garantit rien
inventé tout ça c'est du fait main et ce
qui nous frappe très souvent c'est la
serviabilité nos interlocuteurs tout le
monde a envie de répondre même si on
répond un peu n'importe quoi alors voilà